hi reg good morning gentlemen
how you doing Theodor everything's good
now I wanted to run a couple of things
by you first of all we're trying to come
up with theme music for James Harden and
what should be played in the opposing
teams arena when James is warming up and
of course he travels an awful lot we
also wanted to see if he can get a job
with Travelocity we think they would be
a great spokesperson for Travelocity
okay does he get away with more
traveling okay explain how he gets away
with that yes and I told you he does the
step back and then travels yeah and gets
the shot off yes yeah but I'm people
talked about my leg kick you do whatever
is with it if the refs are not gonna
call the officials are not going to call
it I would do it every day all day but
it is a walk but it's a pretty good walk
though yeah okay jump back Barkley had
this to say with the TNT crew last night
then I want to get your response to this
this is about how great Harden is Kobe
Bryant at 81 points I understand that
there's nobody else's game closed but in
Wilt Chamberlain a Kobe don't have to
say I'm just saying I disagree I think
James Harden's unguardable one-on-one
score like four straight years at one
I'm just telling you James Harden to me
might be the most unguardable player
I've ever seen he's definitely the tough
so what he's saying then Charles is
saying he's more unguardable than
Michael Jordan right I don't think no I
don't think he's saying that we said
he's never seed look I mean encourage
people get this confused because I think
when Charles say that people are like
there's no way he's better than Michael
Jordan or Kobe Bryant no question those
two players are better players than
James Harden well I think what Charles
saying in terms of just straight
one-on-one basketball straight
one-on-one offensive talent only James
Harden is in the top five or his the
best he's ever seen now look no one's on
the same planet as Michael Jordan in
terms of scoring one-on-one basketball I
mean he's on a different planet
but on the same planet with James Harden
I would cut Kobe Bryant I agree with
Kenny Kobe Bryant people people tend to
forget I would also put out what Iverson
on that planet okay
in terms of guys that were unguardable
because I got me to thinking of like you
know most of these guys I played against
obviously I said MJ's on a different
planet then I would put Kobe Allen
Iverson a guy you know I'm talking about
guys I personally played against that to
me were unguardable before the name
juries the rock mitchrichman
he was an unguardable force George
Gervin
I never played against George but I
powdered my game after George cover to
me when you talk about unguardable guys
that are able to score under duress able
to score with two or three players on
you the list that I just put up those
guys didn't matter what type of defense
you put out there against them if you
put a bigger a smaller defender they
will able to post you up they were able
to create off the bounce and that's the
key you've got to be a little to create
your own shot and you've got to be able
to score under duress with one or two
guys in your face hanging on you and you
still got to be able to finish the
basket the guys I mentioned Co v MJ
Gervin Iverson Mitch Richmond and James
Harden
all those guys can create space they can
score under duress and to me they make
their teammates around them better as
well because of their ability to score
the basketball well you bring up
something you added something to it by
being able to create because Kareem is
the most unguardable player in the
history to get right we can hurry with
that yes that's true
he's not gonna beat you off the dribble
we're talking to Reggie's got Spurs and
warriors
at 10:30 tonight on TNT why is Kawhi
Leonard getting a Hall Pass with this
whole situation reg like he doesn't even
show up with the team you know that is
that done is this relationship done it
sure does look like that doesn't it I
don't understand the reason why he can't
travel with the team and being around
the team unless he's in more pain than
we think he is but from what I
understand he's been practicing or tried
to practice so I don't know why he's not
traveling with the team it this is just
a great look for Kauai and the San
Antonio Spurs because the Spurs have
been a a model organization that has
always done things the right way and
this looks like this is a very bad
divorce yeah that's getting ready to
happen between one of the best players
in the league and one of the best
franchises and coaches and organizations
so I just say it doesn't look good it
really does not look good that he's not
a part of you know being in the locker
room and talking to these guys I mean
they were up 20 points before his ankle
injury last year in the playoffs in the
Conference Finals yeah so I think he has
he has a valuable voice on this team and
for him that to be a part of it maybe
maybe he's in the back we don't know is
he is he not on the trip at all do we
know that find out tonight yeah yeah I
think he's in New York like pop says hey
you know I don't know anything about it
ask his guys and but it feels like that
he's done for the playoffs so they're
not expecting him back and I think he
was in New York continuing his rehab
well I believe pop said he was coming
back two months ago and people didn't
want to believe it anyway man one pop
speaks he pretty much you know shoots
from the hip and he wasn't lying so you
know he says we're gonna go with the
guys that are in the locker room and and
that's it but it's not a great look I'm
a huge kalila inner fan and it's just
not a good look for him not to be a part
of this because you know Finals MVP one
of the top five players in my opinion in
the league
one of the best if not the best two-way
players Defensive Player of the Year
you've got to be with your you've got to
be with your teammates how nervous
should the Cavs be you're very nervous
this is the problem you know when you
play LeBron James because so many
players especially the younger
generation at times they get caught ball
watching when you're playing Michael
Jordan excuse when you're playing LeBron
James look like a lot of us did when we
played Michael Jordan because you're at
all the Pacers are not in awe of LeBron
James because of the history dating back
to Miami and last year when he was in
Cleveland Lance Stephenson is not at all
you can care less
so that sprinkles down to your teammates
that sprinkles down to the organization
and to the fans the Indiana fans can
care less about the great LeBron James
because he is great they're fed up
they're fed up of losing to him so that
kind of permeates throughout your team
so that's why they should be nervous
because they caught a team in the first
round that could care less about his
resume as great as it is and will be the
remain objective is to win so that's the
very look this is going to be a long
series it's an every one likes to jump
off the bandwagon after one game and the
Pacers play spectacular and Victor
Oladipo he's shown why the patient Swan
that trade with Paul George but they're
not in awe of LeBron James yeah but I
I'm you know he gets a triple-double
it's it's I there's nobody consistent on
the rest of that roster that's what's
amazing you know there are times when I
watch that team and I go they're just
not a good team you know you had we
talked about this we talked about this
when they made that trade with those
young guys it's great they got younger
but Roddy hood
Larry Nance Jr Jordan Clarkson these
guys are all kind of green great young
talent but they have not gone deep in
the playoffs and two of those three
never been to the playoffs so
as great as it is to have younger talent
and fresh legs on your team it's nice to
have experience and you know who's
getting a Hall Pass to Kevin Love Kevin
Love come on now he's got to step up the
offense should go through him more than
it does you know that's what I would I
would try to correct that I'd probably
have Tristan Thompson play a little bit
more inside because all the Depot was
afraid to go in but I would get the ball
in Kevin love's hands and let him
facilitate a little more than just every
time you throw it to him you expect him
to shoot a jumper and that's the only
time you go to him but I I would try to
do that if I was you know gonna turn
this around a little bit more but I mean
they have guys on that roster Junior
Smith I have no idea what to expect that
it feels like that roster is filled with
I have no idea what to expect you know
the next game and that's that's not the
mark of a even a very good team I agree
but at the end of the day Cleveland fans
it's only one game yes you'll have a
home court advantage but it's one game
and that's why it's the best of seven
series and I've always felt creme will
always rise to the top so you've got the
best player in my opinion in the league
on your team and LeBron James who's gone
into other people's buildings and want
huge Road games so number one you've got
to win Game two at home even the series
and then you gotta find a way to go into
Indiana and and win one which would be
very difficult because Victor Oladipo
and Nate McMillan squad could care less
could care less those payments face your
fans are going to be on and one on one
all right we stumbled upon something we
started the show you know it's one thing
to come up with the 50 greatest players
of all time we've come up with the 50
we're trying to come up with a 50
goodest players of all time
so this is based off al horford now okay
in Paul Millsap Joe Johnson Vlade Divac
but Joe Johnson was it was it all-star
for it is it all you know you could beat
all-stars all right and you can't make
more than 5 on Stu
teams okay like Nick Van Exel was on the
on the goodest players John Starks is a
goodest player michael finley a goodest
player I would put like Eddie Jones
former Laker yeah here's one how about
Ricky Pierce ooh back in the day Ricky
Pierce was a bad boy that lips trim yep
you had a roster full of guys rank you
that you had Dale Davis and Antonio
Davis Rick Rick Vaughn Smiths
Detlef Schrempf Mark Jackson yeah yeah
it's really hard to come up with the 50
goodest players of all time because
these guys were on the fringe of being
great but they were paired with
superstars that sometimes their
challenge got overshadowed but if you
took a poll of locker rooms Mark Jackson
Detlef Ricky Pierce Eddie Jones Nick Van
Exel those guys were the heartbeats of
those teams goodest players who were
some of the other players that we had
McLovin but we had Shareef abdur-rahim
Rashard Lewis who were Shard Lewis lots
of different Mike Bibby was Mike maybe a
gooda spike pipi would like to be pages
on that team oh gee Bobby Jackson Bobby
Jackson Bobby Jack yeah Paulie a lot of
these guys are like great like Jason
Terry
yeah yeah Jason Terry is he might be he
would be the sixth man he's not good
enough to be a starting five on goodest
now we didn't have some controversy here
because Paulie mentioned Kevin Johnson
and it feels like he was better than
being good so he was a very good or not
like he's he's not all the gentlemen
that we just mentioned before Kevin
Johnson will probably never be in the
Hall of Fame Kevin Johnson should be in
the Hall of Fame and he's been nominated
what the last
four or five years so he's on the fringe
of being a Hall of Fame player okay the
other guys we mentioned will not be in
the Hall of Fame Kevin Johnson at some
point in time will be in the Hall of
Fame so you can't make him a goodest
player how about dear you're going to be
in the Hall of Fame Derrick Coleman yes
okay how about that he was but he was
really good go ahead outside Gary Harper
hmm
he's not on the goodest on that team
when he was at his height of that Dallas
Maverick teams what about mark acquire
we thought AG wire might be too good
because he was really yeah to good early
I get first five years you know he's
averaging 24 25 a game he might be too
good okay but he was a great role player
on that piston yes yes when he was
traded to make him a good player along
with Jody Isiah Laimbeer Horne
yeah is Laimbeer a goodest yes well we
were thinking we were thinking Vlade
Divac might be our Center on the goodest
because the toughness factor - I think
I'll roll with Lam beer so Vlade did
more I was a bloody was a better
all-around player naughty debug did you
ever have problems with Laimbeer oh yeah
personally no the Pacers yes because we
were in that black and blue division the
division as the bad boys I don't know
how much time I have left but the best
story ever my rookie year teased of
haniv itch and Bill Laimbeer it was
welcome to the NBA rook moment Steve
depend of itch who was a tough Missouri
seven-foot Center I mean no not that
could have went down before they didn't
knee injury could have been a great
sinner jump ball
I mean I guess he and Lam Barrett had
problems before they go out for jump
ball as soon as the jump ball goes up
Steve's tip and a [ __ ] slaps
bill that beer I mean full-on slaps and
the official stops calls the technical
odds Depot doesn't throw them out you
see like a like a red disk on lamb beers
cheek and like one didn't gel Washington
tear coming down and I'm looking around
the bench like what now I got myself
what is going on here and it was just a
history between those two and they got
him back they got they got steeple back
but I was just like my jaw was on the
ground watching I mean this is jump ball
as soon as the ball goes up here's the
hugest slappin like he just slapped bill
that beer he just slapped it was the
craziest thing like I was like dr. Jack
Ramsay are you sure you want to my legs
were shaking walking out there oh my god
it was great it was great
reg calls tonight's game between the
Spurs and the Warriors that's at 10:30
Eastern on TNT with Kevin Harlan have
fun tonight reg we'll talk to you soon
thanks reg for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]